true because like the other French
French players already been eliminated
so the last one remaining for his
country in this world invitationals I
wonder if he'll be able to clutch it out
the one thing about blue god though
right is that he's very aware of his
surroundings his movement is so his step
guarding is so solid his movements solid
we talked about his punching his
punishing game is godlike yeah you
definitely mentioned his punish cam and
you you could and you are very very
correct but first we're gonna go ahead
and go to a sound bite from skill that
excited from any particular match every
match I'm waiting for every match the
the level itself is gonna be insane I'm
gonna be fine with every every component
I want to find them all
[Music]
and there's skill for you just like that
and do you know what one of the
brightest smiles in the FTC in general
but on top of that incredible player
sake a little bit blue got prior but
let's talk about skill again right we
saw time and time again those perfect
CES he catches you breathing he catches
you back stepping now you're gonna get
caught by it you know what and that's
the thing to write sometimes any solo
charges using use a full fledge of a
full charge
he doesn't just to make sure that he can
put you in a situation are you trying to
guess on him like Oh preemptively it's
you can start using those move somebody
know who's gonna keep it simple and
keeps doing this stuff that's not even a
sole charge special and it's so
brilliant to even think of that but here
we go
blue God punish God let's see what
happens come even is he likes to look
specifically at making sure he's solely
playing okay right he doesn't like the
big injuries because they're big of a
risk right so he wants it he wants to
clean that neutral game up and he wants
to make sure he's eating it that way and
I mean you can see it play a lot of the
time you know you may not be seeing the
biggest of combos from him a lot of the
time you may just be seeing him like
he'll get to get like a sick beat don't
get like a be here no get her there but
it adds up it adds up so fast especially
because to like catch people would make
someone feel frozen and locked up for
movement that's really where you shine
and that's where who's break attacks
that Cup start coming in that's where
his damage starts pumping out but here
we go
heading into Game one with B DG's very
own blue guy versus OPL skill let's get
it rocking
so I mean America's bounce versus uh
Frances success maybe I mean is that
it's available given that the skill has
lost to a certain French frys recently
but already opening up with big damage
fifty-fifty setups here is a lot gonna
be able to at the core for anyone aged
Wow this straight up actually used
arbitrations like that was real that was
it oh yeah there it is again you know
he's trying to catch him I'm sorry okay
I feel like the legend I step right
there but no punish on it and tried to
get the break attacked with a plus brain
and yeah I mean he's eats at the ledge
and the famous move on right but he's
winning so you just want to press too
much he's trying to step
pressure out there again get the leaflet
baby just like that do giving on the
board as well nice and clean and that
was about it in lymphatic as the last
round our a stuff I feel like the entire
time we've been everything LC cube that
has come up like 600 different times in
just regular ass right there oh there's
a Stefano Stein but he does get the stun
on that and trying to get as much damage
as possible the surcharge comes out he
didn't jump so he's gonna get splat it
down Oh caught under it good damage here
but that mix-up is probably scary so he
goes for the sole charge but then the a
thief was he is gonna finish it off
going directly over arbitration
absolution with a few aid by skill but
here we go keep it rocking all night
long going into stance right there
actually so see he's gonna help out
skill having to borrow and I mean we
still got a good amount of life left
right it's definitely not a death
sentence oh and there's that too far at
work right not using the live totals up
and putting it in his favor while he has
an extra bar he stood up on the mid
right there trying to punish the
Stampede no time and there's a step he
gets the low but that's gonna finish it
off it it's two to two in the round
alright who is gonna get the first game
advantage here we go Gilbert those blue
guys both of what and meter to work with
setting up the sword stance but the
thing is saddle up skill to move in
closer and closer to the last Harvey
finally get that nice block on the low
though I warned
no reason Oh got the son right there
okay reset him he actually just did a
weak hit right there so wouldn't
consider accomplice Lee give the muscle
buzzers extra damaged soul chart come
out from skill this is how he makes
something happen but their game one
versus skill I am really surprised that
we God went to forcing skill into
specific situations
normally you and I we you know earlier
we were talking about the fact that he
was doing stuff where it's like oh it's
a punish brain super super well but in
those situations it wasn't just the
frames that were being played at a part
right it was he was forcing skill to do
very specific things and that's how he
was able to get away with stuff like the
8a plus B right get that bubble
activated to do that man try to set him
up he's got a new goal wall right now
okay goes back in the sword stance oh
nice yeah he's pressing but the thing is
the skill doesn't have a lot of life to
gamble with anymore at this point right
there's a block on the wall going on all
right
Luka lift it rip not enough to kill
though BB comes out nah he says speak
the fact that 6b is such a good button
for so many different reasons
creation right there getting catching a
boat verily avoiding that getting
actually damaged and look at how much
damage and just so straight hit he's
already set on blue got caught him near
the wall as well touch me there's two
more double ball shatters yeah not a lot
of help that we got to be able why he
just hit him wrong with that and then
there's the a k14 the sole charge he's
not a near the wall there's the GI we GI
but no events at the combo and then
skill he's kind of get the punish on it
what a bit drop not to date that's gonna
go to clash on each other talk like
there's a big twitch talking to get some
legal hit on this big damage he's gonna
be able to put him near the wall to
meter for skill and two rounds for him
as well lugar getting really swiftly the
beginning of the ground already junk at
him jab close than 50% of mark that's
one of the nice parts about that
fifty-fifty set up off the back turn
right he's gonna be able to get the
almighty beyblade on this one
okay one game apiece I think as well
finally an a small player finally
figured out what it feels like to be oh
my god I mean I mean that's the power of
soul charge for a lot of characters to
be quite honest with you that leads them
into either more tech situations these
situations we're gonna be on correctly
back in every match so fast yeah I have
never seen a rematch bad fashion caliber
I don't think yo lose always like run
that back run that back right now give
me that I had that let's go at the wall
you get that wall but right now is
Munsell but there bang I lost this time
and the life of those are slowly
questionable way you know if you got
does have sort of camps right now but if
he gets in that face it's not all caught
under it getting in the leaflets ooh
look at the damage forcing the soul
chart right now he's got to show the
power isn't freezing he's naked he got
the wall hit gonna get a little bit of
extra damage
there's the muscle buster but he hasn't
gotten up for the 50/50 great option by
still then step with the fingers in the
shoulder check caught in the wall
breaker there's AAA
skill set point right now alright bring
it back we know that he is the
punishment god I like that right there
so we got actually get to the duck
option to try to be a little punished if
and you know he kept pressing lady was
able to catch him once he stood up that
should do it right there and skill is
gonna put blue got its own
skill taking it to once as I'm same man
that his punish came is so clean it's so
clean you definitely mentioned it before
for sure you know having the God
punished versus the God of photo shoot
it really just matters when the
situation comes up and now that
solidifies our winners whiners